the chinese communist party knows what
happened here they know who patient zero
was they know precisely where this began
we need to get to the bottom of this
because this could happen again
so that's mike pompeo with us yesterday
suspicions growing about the origins of
cove and impossible links from that lab
in wuhan china
there's a group of republicans demanding
answers concerning research
possibly funded by the u.s senator ron
johnson is among the lawmakers leading
that effort center good morning to you
why has why has the mainstream media
taken a sudden interest in this
leak lab leak story well first of all
one of their own finally issued and
wrote a very important article nicholas
wade
a former new york times science reporter
really laid out the case
for a lab
source of this virus and so now all of a
sudden it's acceptable but you know
this the evidence of a the creation of
this in lab or the leaking of a lab
from a lab has been hidden in plain
sight for literally months
but the mainstream media just won't pick
it up in the story and unfortunately dr
fauci papooed it
uh dismissed it ridiculed it and so i
think a group of senators and and mike
gallagher as well
in the house we want honest and complete
answers from dr fauci and dr collins
well when fauci was asked about it a few
days ago he seemed to suggest that he
every theory is still alive what did you
make of that comment to paraphrase him
well he's finally being honest
but he was dismissive a year ago and you
have to ask yourself why
you know why was so dismissive something
that was really pretty obvious and you
also have to ask the media
why do they vilify people like senator
cotton who came out and
again what just relayed was an obvious
truth that this is certainly a
possibility
falci's direct quote was i'm not
convinced we should continue to
investigate in china i mentioned pompeo
with us yesterday here's how he
um when asked the question as to whether
or not we will ever know
here is the former secretary of state
this would have been early january of
2020
when we were still trying to figure out
precisely what was about to hit the
world and the chinese communist party
had gone completely dark
they wouldn't take our phone calls they
wouldn't answer our questions we sent
inquiries we couldn't get a straight
answer our ambassador
ambassador branstad couldn't get a
straight answer the chinese communist
party clearly knew they had a problem
they didn't want the world to know it
and i'm convinced they still know they
have a problem and don't want us to know
and the question then is will we ever
know senator
uh let's hope so but we need to also
have the full story here as well
our letter is really asking nih director
collins
to tell us more about this gain of
function
uh pause and also the exception
for you know national security concerns
and reasons so so we
asked something like 17 questions that
are really kind of getting to the heart
of issue in terms of
what the u.s government health agencies
funded in terms of gains
gain function research creating chimeric
viruses
and how we cooperated with for example
dr xi who
worked at the wuhan lab so again all
this has been available for months the
evidence has been hidden in plain sight
the media hasn't wanted to pick it up
and certainly dr fauci hasn't wanted to
really talk about it when he does talk
about it
he uses he uses v he uses very lawyerly
phrases
and that just increases my uh uh
curiosity i was hearing senator a week
ago when you had the back and forth with
rand paul fauci pretty much suggested
that there was no u.s money that that
went toward gain of function
did he not say that in the back and
forth well again it was a very
lawyerly response and you have to parse
his words very carefully
and i think our letter is really
designed to not allow them to parse
their words anymore we're just asking
straight up questions
i'm hoping they on answer them honestly
and completely
but i'm also hoping that investigative
members of the press
also look into this and start asking
these very same questions senator thank
you for coming on today
and we shall continue to ask the
questions in due course thank you
senator ron johnson have a good day